and following the footsteps of so many
who have made ronda their home and have
flourished here
so as i said this partnership builds on
our record of caring for refugees and
welcoming migrants
and we will be able to provide not just
a safe haven
these people are looking for
but the opportunity to build new lives
here and develop alongside rwandans
so we're happy to take your questions
now
we'll be answering in english french and
king aranda so feel free to ask
in any language that you want
we will not be translating
for expediency's sake we have
less than an hour to do this
but if you'd like to know what question
was asked and and the answer would be
happy to tell you after the press
conference
so um i kindly ask that you keep your
questions short because we'd like
everyone to get a chance to ask
so let's get started
my name is ann soy from the bbc there's
been an outcry in the uk about this deal
and there are legal challenges are you
concerned about this outcry and
isn't the government here uh enabling
something that's highly unpopular in the
uk and internationally
should we take off one by one
okay
thank you anne
um
we uh we're doing this for the right
reasons as i just
outlined in my
uh in my statement earlier we're doing
this for the right reasons we have the
experience
we we want ronda to be a welcoming place
for people in precarious uh conditions
and we're determined to make this work
uh we understand that there might be uh
opposition to this but we are asking
that the this program be given a chance
because it's a solution they're not many
solutions uh people are suffering uh the
asylum system
is broken it's being taken advantage of
by
criminal gangs that are exploiting
people
making false promises
people are risking their lives
in these dangerous crossings so
something has to give and we are happy
to be working on this uh solution with
the with our uk partners
next question please
shiny
morocco
foreign
is
foreign
foreign
um i'll ask the same question again
okay i heard it thank you
it depends uh different from what
we're expecting migrants from all over
the world
uh people coming from you know
countries with conflict uh some may have
been you know persecuted from where
they're coming from they're coming from
maybe countries that don't have
opportunities and we think that uh
that
a lot of them have uh misconception
about what ronda is like and what africa
is like and to be quite honest some of
this is perpetuated by media uh
you know that does not reflect the the
reality of of of our countries so we
they should uh you know uh we will give
them an opportunity to see what it's
like uh to live in this country we do
not consider living in rather a
punishment we don't think anyone should
i mean you you're
you're here i i don't know what what
your impression is and what impression
you had before
you came here but uh we're doing our
best to provide the
conducive environment uh for london's to
develop and for anyone else who comes to
live here with us
yes paul
thank you
the church of england has said today
that this is an immoral policy and a
moral policy that's their words
as a christian nation how do you respond
to
that uh we are christian muslim
and you know many other
religions here we don't think it's
immoral to offer a home to people
something that we have done here uh for
more than 30 years
and we're doing this for the right
reasons so people may have their own
opinions uh about what this program is
like depending on where they're coming
from but from where we coming from we're
doing this for the right reasons we want
to be a welcoming place and we'll do our
best to make sure that the migrants are
taking care of and that they're able to
build a life here
on
is
this is also an opportunity for rwanda
to be part of a solution
as i said uh before there is a huge
global imbalance in opportunities
uh you know this is why young people
feel that they have to make dangerous
journeys to go make their lives
elsewhere
africa is not just a place of uh
of problems as as is often portrayed in
the media it's also a place for
solutions
we are proud to be part of a solution of
an innovative program that is providing
a solution to a sticky problem so this
is also an advantage for us to be part
of a partnership like this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
um
what would you say to rwandans who
wonder why these asylum seekers are
going to live in better conditions than
they are
um
we have we are under the obligation to
in this partnership to provide a you
know decent accommodation it's not
luxurious but it'll be dignified and and
decent which is what we try to do with
our limited means for all all rwandans
and in addition as my colleague said
this is a migration an economic
development partnership as well so there
will be investments in
in the host community to raise the
standards of living for everybody in
terms of infrastructure and training so
all london's benefit from this as well
also if i may when do you expect the
first arrival of asylum seekers sent
here from denmark
we haven't concluded
our talks with the danish
yet
hello thank you very much my name is
clement from reuters uh philippe
publishing the primary secretary from
the ministry in charge of emergency said
that there's a possibility of
resettlement to other countries for
these migrants from uk can you please
share right on that because this is new
thanks and you can tell us which
countries because uk is not part of them
thanks
for these migrants and asylum seekers
resettlement
life in another country is part of the
developer solutions we have local
integration
we have
repatriation to country of origin and we
have also possibilities for resettlement
so
for for this
maybe the government
the true government will not be
dealt involved but
whoever among those migrants will be
able to
who will wish to go for another country
to live in another country
who will receive
the
will be accepted
in that country we will facilitate the
process of free muharram uh being
transferred to that country
thank you
hi it's uh jack hardy from the daily
telegraph can i just ask um how many
flights rwanda are prepared to receive
from the uk uh and equally when the next
one is scheduled for
so we don't have a final number we don't
have a specific number we are in
discussions with our partners in the uk
uh we're we're you know ready to receive
thousands over the life of of this
partnership but we don't have uh
an exact number for now
the next flight uh not sure
we're waiting to hear from
from our uk partners
and just as an example when we offered
to host the migrants were
stuck in libya who we evacuated here our
president offered up to 30 000 at the
time when he was president of the
african union we've had about a thousand
so far so we have capacity for a lot of
migrants
[Music]
foreign
thank you my name is magnus from tarifa
i want to know if one of or more
migrants will be interested in settling
and
become rondon
what are the
legal processes and how long does it
take
can you give us a legal process through
which one would become a random at a
later stage if they're interested
the primary purpose of this partnership
is to provide a legal status for people
who live in this country
so the people who live in this country
will be given several legal avenues
for legal residents the primary one will
be to be granted refugee status
if not refugee status they will be
granted a residence on other grounds
such as migrant worker status and other
with the view of acquiring citizenship
there are legal paths to citizenship for
migrant workers and for refugees
provided they
they
are eligible under the criterias for
citizenship so there is a pathway a
clear pathway that will be communicated
to them to become randoms this is one of
the primary objectives of this
settlement program
is that they will be treated like
rondons
um yeah sorry
okay um i got the mic here
[Music]
when will article 16 of the agreement be
first implemented when will the first
vulnerable refugees be able to depart
towards the uk will be on the return
flight tomorrow from kigali to uk
can you please repeat that okay over
here when will article 16 of the
agreement be implemented
okay i don't know if it's this one okay
either way so when will article 16 be
implemented when will the first
vulnerable refugees from rwanda be able
to depart towards the uk will there be
some on the flight on the return flight
tomorrow from kigali to the uk
the spirit of article 16
is to reflect this shared
understanding that we share
responsibilities in
resettling vulnerable refugees from both
countries
it is a reflection also of the fact that
there are legal pathways to immigrate in
the uk
however
you need to understand that
vulnerabilities
those vulnerabilities that would require
um
settlement into the uk
are very few and far between we do not
have
an estimate on how many will be settled
to the uk it's going to be
those for those very outlier
cases because again
as my colleagues put it this is an
economic development partnership as well
so we will be better equipped to
accommodate those vulnerabilities
no they won't be
rwanda
[Music]
[Music]
um
refugees
[Music]
yes
sue reed from the daily mail
in london um
do you know the backgrounds of the
migrants you'll be
receiving
in the next 24 hours
and how will you the asylum process in
rwanda help
i mean uh proceed if you find
some of the arrivals actually have got a
criminal record either
in their home countries
uh as they crossed you know uh to to
northern europe and then to bri or in
the uk
we do uh in terms of the memorandum of
understanding with the uk we do reserve
the rights to request certain
information uh in accordance with both
of our privacy laws however if uh if it
is to be
um
if we also have the right to um reject
uh any submitted request for transfer of
a relocated individual if we feel they
would be a threat to national security
however
we do recognize that people with
criminal records can also be refugees it
just is a matter of what what the level
or the gravity of the crimes they're
accused of
before i give magnus a second
opportunity
yes go ahead edwin
thank you my name is edwin mussoni from
the new times
are there some
entertainment arrangements planned for
these refugees upon arrival
and for those that will be qualified and
able to get jobs can they secure jobs in
the government thank you
at accommodation facility
we have prepared for entertainment
facilities and tools
we have playgrounds we have indoors
games but we identify more once the
the migrants and the refugees are there
we want also them to participate and
give us recommendations so that we can
even offer what fits in their their
wishes
for the the
the migrant refugees getting jobs i
think that our labor
laws
allow
refugees asylum seekers but especially
refugees to
to be eligible on
different
jobs
including the government you have some
refugees that are unemployed by the
government so this will not be different
for this group of
refugees and migrants
thank
foreign
foreign
thank you
i'm called becca in for our trides
podcast so i have like three questions
the first question is
why are these uh people been chosen in
particular
the migrants that are coming
so the second question is uh there are
kids or minors in the migrants that are
coming in
the third question is what are the
economic benefits
uh from the government of the uk
does the rundown government receive from
hosting these uh people
from uk
then is there an is
the fourth question
is there uh
the last date when this agreement will
end or you have not agreed on any debt
to end this agreement
the first question is uh
why are these people in particular like
how have you selected the migrants to
bring in rwanda
the people selected under this
partnership reflect the issue that we
are trying to contribute to addressing
which is uh irregular
migration which places these people
uh in the hands of uh people traffickers
so this will be people who have crossed
into the uk illegally
we're trying to curb this illegal
migration that is costing lives
and
your second question was the lifetime of
this partnership it is a renewable
memorandum of understanding that will
last five years
however we do intend to at a later stage
turn it into a binding treaty i don't
remember your other questions
yes there will not be any unaccompanied
minors under this partnership
but we do stand ready at a later stage
to receive families
sorry
this is a migration and economic
development partnership we are we
recognize the value that migrants bring
to a society they have much to
contribute
uh in terms of um they can contribute to
a culture they can contribute to
creation of livelihoods there is also a
an economic development component that
will raise the standard of living for
rwandans and all who reside in rwanda
hi emine synmas from the guardian and
while the applications are being
processed will they will there be any
restrictions on the movement of the
asylum seekers and can they come and go
as they please will they be subjected to
a curfew will there be guards
um
first of all uh no because uh the
accommodation the facility is not a
detention facility so
uh they will be free to come and go as
the case is looked at um and uh but
there were there there is security at
the hope hostel which many of you
visited because you know uh for their
own safety as well it's um
it's a facility that's in a residential
neighborhood it's right on the main road
so uh we need to ensure that the
migrants are safe
yeah
there will be some in-house rules uh i
think uh
as they are in many
accommodation centers
in many parts of the world i i've seen
that in in london as well so there will
be some some it's some you know a few
guidelines on how
the space will be used
just
basic housekeeping rules yeah just basic
housekeeping rules in a for shared
facility that's home to many people
nothing nothing special
hey buddy
uh catherine you and i have spoken a lot
but go ahead please
sorry john
it's all right thank you
um
i'm just wondering about the third
option that you're going to give the
asylum seekers should they want to go to
a third country can you take us through
the mechanics of that what are you going
to do what is the process like
and do you have any experience um
you know with successful cases that you
have relocated to third countries
especially considering that and i'm not
talking about the gashora one because
that's when the unhcr i believe does
that and the unhcr has been critical of
this this deal
do you have any experience of doing it
successfully and how are you going to do
it
this is a
mechanism to resettle people in london
society the primary objective is to
fully integrate them in random society
it is not to
send them off to other countries however
we recognize that people have freedom of
movement and should they wish
to move to a third country where they
would have legal residence we will
facilitate that movement however the
random government will not be
involved in the application to that
third country but we will facilitate
access to that third country once legal
residence is established
this is just a recognition of the
freedom of movement in and out of the
country
basically uh one a fair example would be
for instance if a person comes from a
region with uh and for instance in east
africa you can reside in several
countries by being a national of an east
african country so if the person feels
that the country of origin may not be
safe but they do have
already existing legal residence they
would be facilitated provided that
country is uh willing to
to accommodate them
if i can add to that it's this is a new
partnership so
we'll see how it works and and for for
that kind of question it will be on a
case-by-case basis so the kind of
facilitation we would have for instance
is if they want to reunite with family
in another third country and they're
able to go there then we'll give them
travel documents to travel to that
country it will really be on a
case-by-case basis
we'll see
we'll see how it develops
we do have a working partnership with
the unit crs as you said and you know in
resettling people from refugee camps and
from the gashora emergency transit
mechanism so
all these options are open
no we haven't gotten there yet
we're expecting the first ones tomorrow
let's see how it goes but we're very
open to you know adapting um
this uh this program to you know to you
know to suit the needs of uh
of those who are coming to you know on
the possible options
for now yes it's a government government
thank you very much everybody
you